bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur
TVfil 78 pour une nouvelle édition du
journal du lundi au vendredi 18h et
aujourd'hui dans les titres pas moins de
4 projets d'aménagement pour
Voisins-le-Bretonneux de nouveau
logement de nouvelles infrastructures
dans les prochaines années mercredi soir
hier lancement de la réflexion avec les
habitants sur le futur cœur de ville
anticipez les déplacements de demain
mission des collectivités locales la
communauté d'agglomération vient
d'éditer son nouveau plan en la matière
prioritée accordée à la mobilité durable
et puis inviter de cette édition le
clash de 50 ans en Yvelines le comité
local pour le logement autonome des
jeunes 20 ans d'action et un constat la
situation actuelle est préoccupante
le maire en tête la remise ou encore la
manivelle autant de quartiers que la
ville de Voisins-le-Bretonneux souhaite
voir évoluer plusieurs projets
d'aménagements sont en cours autour
d'horizon de leurs avancées avec Yolaine
Torres
voisin le Bretonneux une ville en
perpétuelle évolution où les
aménagements et les projets ne manquent
pas parmi les principaux du moment celui
dit cœur de ville hier soir en salle du
conseil municipal une réunion publique
était proposée aux habitants la
municipalité a présenté le diagnostic
d'une étude sur le sujet une sorte
d'état des lieux du centre-ville de
voisin à long terme l'objectif est d'en
changer la physionomie aujourd'hui on a
un centre commercial qui est bien séparé
du centre de la vie culturelle et
administrative de la ville et donc
peut-être les commerces qui sont du côté
administratif souffrent plus que ceux
qui sont de l'autre côté et on n'a pas
de vrais centralité dans notre ville
mais c'est l'historique c'est un petit
village avant donc forcément les voix
sont toutes petites elles sont pas bien
dimensionnées les trottoirs non plus
d'ailleurs voilà donc ça nous permet
d'envisager l'avenir en parlant d'un
futur plus lointain de nouvelles lois de
circulation pour désengorger le centre
sont également évoqués suite à cette
réunion publique deux ateliers de
travail seront mis en place avec les
habitants pour imaginer avec eux le
centre de demain autre projet phare du
moment celui du maire hanté appelé aussi
projet Nymphéa le programme prévoit de
construire ici 43 logements 34 logements
locatifs sociaux et 9 maisons de ville
on a une problématique de logement
social puisque c'est une ville qui est
très résidentielle très pavillonnaire
donc qui s'est construit depuis les
années 70 essentiellement et donc avec
la loi céru et puis la loi du flow de
l'an dernier on doit atteindre 25% de
logements locatif sociaux afin de créer
un véritable lieu de vie sociale et de
permettre aux riverains de se réunir une
salle de quartier sera également bâtie
le chantier vient de démarrer il devrait
être terminé dans 18 mois
un peu plus loin le secteur de la remise
un projet d'écoquartier qui s'étend sur
10 hectares de terrain est en cours
l'objectif principal est clair répondre
aux besoins de logement avec la
construction d'un peu moins de 500
habitations la population de voisins
baisse d'année en année les jeunes gens
n'ont plus de n'ont pas tellement
d'endroits pour loger parce que c'est
quand même extrêmement cher et donc il
est nécessaire d'avoir une offre de
logement assez diversifiée pour
permettre ce qu'on appelle un parcours
résidentiel au jeune couple qui
voudraient démarrer dans la vie et puis
continuer à vivre sur voisin après le
périmètre de la zone d'aménagement
concerté est acté il englobe tout le
terrain de la remise le carrefour des
pyramides à côté et la pointe collège
aujourd'hui le dossier est lancé et
avance autre aménagement dont on entend
un peu moins parler pour le moment celui
des terrains de la manivelle et des
mouettes l'endroit devait accueillir au
départ un établissement d'hébergement
pour personnes âgées dépendantes mais
suite à la décision de l'ARS et de
France et du Conseil Général des
Yvelines cet établissement se fait
finalement sur la ville de on a cherché
des solutions pour essayer de loger des
personnes âgées mais c'est un domaine
très complexe parce que il faut que ce
soit financé par le département et le
département finances presque plus rien
pour dire ce qui est donc pour l'instant
on est revenu
à un projet je dirais plus classique
plus classique de logement prochaine
étape réexpliquer ce projet au riverains
et se concerter avec eux
on reste à voisin le Bretonneux avec ce
test pour fluidifier la circulation qui
est menée depuis le mois de septembre
l'expérimentation était lancée au
croisement de la route de trappe et de
Versailles point de passage souvent
engorgé circulation modifiée rythme des
feux également la mairie a mis en ligne
un questionnaire sur le site sur son
site internet pour recueillir les
différents avis près de 200 habitants y
ont déjà répondu
ce qu'il en ressort c'est un petit peu
embêtant parce qu'en fait c'est pour
certaines personnes pour les personnes
qui traversent vos voisins c'est plus
fluide pour d'autres qui viendraient de
l'autre côté c'est moins fluide un peu
un sentiment de la sécurité parce que
les gens savent pas forcément comment
prendre ce rond-point donc j'ai
prochainement on est en train de
programmer un nouveau rendez-vous avec
le Conseil Général qui pilote cette
expérimentation pour faire un point et
voir est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on pérennise
ce système où est-ce qu'on essaye autre
chose voilà on reste dans le domaine des
transports et l'agglomérations de 50 ans
en Yvelines qui vient de présenter son
plan local de déplacement un plan pour
définir les aménagements réaliser les
actions à mener la mobilité durable
étalonneur afin de répondre au projet de
l'île de France de réduire de 20% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2020 Mélanie pocket
donner envie aux gens d'abandonner leur
voiture pour privilégier les transports
en commun une volonté maintes fois
répétée des agglomérations et pouvoir
public et pourtant les usagers ne sont
pas toujours satisfaits
bien mais c'est vrai que dès que il y a
un petit incident ça complique aussi à
quelle heure on part on sait pas à
quelle heure on arrive franchement tous
les jours il y a des problèmes des
retard par-ci par-là 470
000 c'est le nombre de déplacements
qu'effectue en moyenne chaque jour les
50 chinois 51% de ces déplacements sont
faits en voiture seulement 15% le son en
transport en commun le PLD vise allait
rendre plus attractif ça va être un peu
plus long terme des projets de voies
réservés pour les bus pour relier les
deux côtés de l'agglomération il y a des
itinéraires qui vont de la gare de
Saint-Quentin vers la clef Saint-Pierre
de la gare de Saint-Quentin vers trappes
la verrière et l'idée c'est que ces
lignes de bus puisse après dans le futur
basculer et puisse rejoindre l'avenue où
il y a déjà un TCS qui existent les
améliorations porteront sur les
infrastructures mais aussi sur les
services comme l'information directe à
l'usager avec des indications en temps
réel aux arrêts bus ou encore la mise en
place d'une Vélo Station pour louer à
moyen ou à court terme des vélos en
garde 50 ans des modifications viseront
aussi les réseaux ferrés en multipliant
l'offre des lignes n etu et le RER C qui
lui ira notamment jusqu'à la gare de
Coignières pour les usagers ça veut dire
que pour les gens qui habitent à La
Verrière trappes Élancourt il pourrait
prendre plus directement et plus
facilement le RER C notamment au niveau
de trappe et la verrière on serait pas
obligé de faire un changement en gare de
Saint-Quentin prendre un bus et ensuite
de devoir prendre le RER C les premières
modifications seront visibles d'ici un
an et demi le projet vise la réalisation
de la ligne 18 du métro du Grand Paris
avant 2030
le faisceau il est à peu près acté ce
qui n'est pas acté aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir si on fait de l'aérien et du
souterrain et sur fait donc deux gars ou
une gare le problème c'est que
l'enveloppe financière est elle est
figée et donc il faut qu'on trouve les
bonnes solutions si on fait une gare et
c'est la réflexion que nous avons
aujourd'hui comment on peut faire vivre
les transports de Saint-Quentin avec une
gare quelle intermodalité faut-il avoir
comment on va raccorder l'ensemble des
autres réseaux à cette gare et quels
sont les capacités que l'on aurait de
dire finalement une gare en souterrain
c'est beaucoup d'avantages en termes de
nuisances environnementale et finalement
on arrive à trouver des voies de
fonctionnement sur l'ensemble des
réseaux de surface voire Ferrer ou voir
des trames trains lésions avec la TGO
est-ce que je sais qui permettent
d'avoir une vraie réponse de transport
en commun sur Saint-Quentin connecté à
la n18 on aurait une réunion de travail
avec d'autres élus du territoire le 4
décembre donc ça nous permet d'avancer
très très concrètement je voudrais vous
rappeler que c'est un enjeu majeur je
pense que si on regarde non pas pour les
années qui viennent mais pour les
décennies qui viennent c'est sans doute
en matière de projet de développement un
des enjeux essentiels le clash le comité
local pour le logement autonome des
jeunes de 50 ans en Yvelines n'existe
depuis maintenant 20 ans l'occasion donc
de dresser un bilan de leurs actions de
porter un regard également sur les
conditions d'accession au logement nous
en parlons plus en détail dans un
instant avec nos invités sur ce plateau
responsable de la structure mais tout de
suite pour un premier point ce reportage
de Catherine zulator
20 ans que le clash s'occupe de trouver
des solutions de logement pour les 18-30
ans sur l'agglomération 5 continents et
les communes aux alentours des solutions
en parc social en parc privé ou des
solutions temporaires dans des foyers de
jeunes travailleurs 20 ans leur débilant
16000 jeunes accueillis 7500 accompagnés
70% de nos logements dans le logement de
droit commun essentiellement dans le
parc social les choses changent un petit
peu au jour d'aujourd'hui on a plus de
mal à trouver des solutions adaptées le
marché est extrêmement tendu et on a des
situations qui se sont précarisées pour
le public en demande des contrats plus
précaires et des ressources souvent qui
stagnent nous voir qui baisse donc on
observe aujourd'hui une augmentation du
des relogements dans le parc dit
temporaire foyer de jeunes travailleurs
résidence sociale c'est vrai qu'en
entretient les jeunes sont de plus en
plus enfin avec des petits contrats
soit des CDD soit de l'intérim soit des
CDI à temps partiel donc c'est vrai que
les loger enfin ça devient de plus en
plus difficile chaque année le clash
accompagne 350 nouveaux jeunes la durée
de cet accompagnement individualisé et
variable cela peut aller de trois mois à
plusieurs années le type de population
accueillie est très divers on accueille
des jeunes déco habitants on accueille
des jeunes qui sortent justement de
foyer jeune travailleur qui sont en
recherche de logement autonome on
accueille des jeunes qui sont hébergés
chez des tiers on accueille vraiment
tout type de public mais majoritairement
des petits ménages donc des jeunes seuls
ou un couple sans enfant et souvent des
jeunes avec des ressources qui sont
entre 0,8 et 1,2 fois le SMIC en 2013
l'équipe du clash a estimé qu'il
manquait 150 places en foyer de jeunes
travailleurs pour absorber les demandes
un projet de construction de 180 places
non loin du Vélodrome seraient prévu
d'ici la fin de l'année une bonne
nouvelle pour le comité local qui a
ouvert un nouveau site Internet il est
possible dorénavant de s'y inscrire les
services du clash sont gratuits
en plateau à présent Sylvie Veil et Paul
Gino bonsoir à tous les deux
vice-présidente président donc de ce
clash de 50 ans en Yvelines et des
communes avoisinantes on vient
d'entendre au cours du reportage qu'il
manquait 150 places pour faire face à la
demande dans les foyers de jeunes
travailleurs ces jeunes qui ne trouvent
pas de place aujourd'hui ils deviennent
quoi ils vont se loger encore plus loin
il soit il reste chez leurs parents s'il
le peuvent alors qu'ils souhaitaient
ou bien
il trouve des sites des lieux
d'hébergement tels qu'un foyer jeune
travailleur ou encore ils habitent
de façon très aléatoire c'est des amis
vous parlez de cette galère justement il
y a matière à s'inquiéter ou plutôt être
rassuré là aussi dans le sujet il était
question de d'un éventuel foyer qui
pourraient ouvrir du côté du vélo de
route de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines oui
est-ce qu'il faut sont satisfaire
c'est un non il faut c'est
évidemment très satisfait de cette
ouverture là
il s'agit d'une organisation régionale
qui implante un nouveau une résidence
pour jeune actif mais qui arrive aussi
avec une clientèle à elle donc qu'elle
part sera réservée aux jeunes du
territoire Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
nous ne savons pas mais c'est une très
bonne nouvelle bien sûr
élargit un petit peu on voit ces jeunes
qui sont toujours bloqués et
éventuellement je posais la question
est-ce que ces jeunes aussi s'éloignent
encore plus du bassin et ce qu'il trouve
des logements plus loin dans d'autres
projets difficiles ça leur est très
difficile on n'a pas de d'observatoire
assez fins encore on a un observatoire
qui nous permet et là je fais une petite
remarque c'est pas 150 mais 250 places
dont on aurait besoin dans les années
qui viennent parce qu'il n'y a pas que
les jeunes qui sont en capacité de se
loger en foyer de jeunes travailleurs il
y a aussi les jeunes qu'on appelle nous
aux jeunes en insertion qui sont encore
que ça de l'emploi un peu stabilisé
qu'il faut avoir pour être en foyer de
jeunes travailleurs les jeunes vraiment
précaires ils ont besoin de de logement
de transition ils ont besoin de choses
comme ça
aujourd'hui avec la précarisation des
emplois et les difficultés à accéder
déjà à l'emploi peut il faut ils sont
pas comme un jeune couple qui a déjà un
salaire prêt à partir à 100 km de Paris
c'est pas du tout leur démarche ils
habitent là ils sont là et ils ont
besoin de trouver pas trop loin de leur
milieu et de leurs copains et de leur
famille un petit un petit truc un petit
logement un petit quelque chose mais ils
en sont pas dans des projets encore de
d'installation de de domiciliation
dans les jeunes ont besoin on va tout de
suite écouter un micro-trottoir notre
question du jour qui vous a été posée
dans les rues de 50 ans en Yvelines
aujourd'hui par Guillaume Lachenal vous
êtes jeune comment avez-vous trouvé ou
non d'ailleurs votre logement
alors je l'ai trouvé sur un site qui
s'appelle adèle.org j'avais essayé par
le creux etc mais bon comme d'habitude
j'ai enfin j'ai jamais eu de réponse en
octobre sachant que je cherchais depuis
juillet donc oui ça a été extrêmement
compliqué mais au final je trouvais par
rapport à ça pour une résidence privée
parce que aucune réponse du CROUS j'ai
pas cherché parce que de toute façon
j'ai pas les revenus qui me permettent
d'avoir un je m'en et puis je suis à une
demi-heure d'ici donc ça va j'ai
contacté en fait le CROUS j'ai appelé
après ils m'ont envoyé plein de dossiers
et tout ça à remplir et puis voilà mais
en fait il y a plein de documents à
rendre donc c'est mieux de s'y prendre à
l'avance
c'est compliqué ou alors c'est même la
fatalité tant pis je reste je reste chez
mes parents c'est un petit peu ce qu'on
a entendu là est-ce qu'il faut aussi
réfléchir c'est peut-être la réflexion
que vous avez un autre mode de logement
de logement je pense à
l'intergénérationnel par exemple les
seniors qui accueillent les jeunes ça se
fait de plus en plus c'est ce que les
jeunes aussi sont demandeurs de ça les
jeunes qui viennent vous voir c'est une
policeibilité qui est intéressante les
personnes âgées qui se trouvent dans un
appartement qui est devenu trop grand et
qui souhaite avoir une présence mais
évidemment ça demande un binôme qui soit
organisé entre la personne âgée et le
jeune tous les jeunes ne peuvent pas ne
peuvent pas convenir donc c'est une
c'est une piste intéressante je reviens
au clash au fonctionnement que vous avez
aujourd'hui un jeune qui est en
difficulté pour trouver un logement qui
vient vous voir ça se passe comment pour
lui comment est-il accueilli et comment
ça se passe au clash deux temps d'abord
il appelle on a un millier d'appels de
nouvelles appels chaque année
j'ai pas redonné toutes les autres
communes mais c'est 50 ans en Yvelines
j'ai plus la liste Bois-d'Arcy
Coignières
qui nous écoutent donc entre 18 et 50 et
30 ans et reçu au clair et là on lui
propose un entretien approfondi ou rien
ne remplace le face à face notre
conseiller logement qui connaît bien son
métier et qui sait s'intéresser au cas
d'un jeune en recherche de logement et
le on l'aide à faire son parcours pour
trouver quelque chose on ne fait pas les
démarches à sa place mais on lui dit on
lui propose des démarches à faire et on
l'aide dans ces démarches on
l'accompagne et rien ne remplace un
accompagnement dans un circuit aussi
difficile que se trouvait à ce sujet
alors le clash est en relation avec les
bailleurs avec les prescripteurs de
logement donc peut mettre le jeûne en
relation avec des bailleurs et
d'ailleurs les bailleurs qui souhaitent
vous mettre en location leur appartement
peuvent vous contacter vous faites tout
à fait dire on a des contacts très
réguliers organisés avec les bailleurs
dans le reportage dans le micro-trottoir
vous aviez des étudiants qui répondaient
oui c'est très difficile il faut
beaucoup de papiers c'est compliqué etc
ça prend du temps alors imaginez pour un
jeune qui n'a pas forcément tous les
outils
sociétaux
un étudiant en général il a ses papiers
il s'est les rangés c'est les classer et
les retrouve et c'est ce que c'est
qu'une déclaration d'impôts et un jeune
de 18 ans qui n'a pas encore fait de
déclaration d'impôts pour constituer son
dossier il va avoir du mal vous êtes là
aussi pour ça c'est la vocation du clash
de l'aider à constituer tous les
éléments comment est né le clash
justement c'est à 20 ans donc c'est
l'occasion de refaire un bilan c'est une
volonté nationale aussi qu'est-ce que ça
a été décliné à travers tout le temps
national
les ministères c'était aperçus que dans
le parcours d'insertion d'un jeune le
logement est absolument un passage
obligé plusieurs ministères avaient déjà
créé des réseaux d'information par
exemple le ministère de la Jeunesse avec
les bureaux d'information Jonas les
bijoux les piges en ce qui concerne le
ministère du Travail des affaires
sociales via les missions locales les
PAO pour l'éducation nationale des CROUS
mais de façon interministérielle en
s’est aperçu que le logement était un
blocage à tous ces dispositifs et qu'il
fallait un dispositif spécifique accès
au logement et une circulaire
interministérielle signée du six
ministères a créé ces fameux clashs
comité locale pour le logement autonome
des jeunes
encore des logements des foyers de
jeunes travailleurs des places pour
accueillir tout le monde mais le bilan
est positif ou
nous accueillons
nous recevons un millier d'appels chaque
année nous accueillons et nous suivons
environ 350 nouveaux jeunes et pour 45%
ont trouvé une solution d'après ce qu'on
connaît il y a peut-être des jeunes qui
trouvent des solutions et qui nous le
disent pas mais parmi ceux que nous
suivons 45% trouve des solutions et sur
le regard de l'ensemble des plages en
France nous sommes une centaine une
petite centaine oui c'est positif le
fait d'accompagner un jeune dans la
recherche en juin et très positive la
pérennité toutes les structures est
toujours régulièrement remise en cause
surtout en période économique difficile
parce que c'est le cas forcément
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les choses vont
bien sur ce point de vue là comment est
financer le clash déjà on va revenir au
début et puis est-ce que c'est assuré
pour les prochaines années le
financement est un peu compliqué c'est
un empilement de financement ce qui fait
que c'est assez fragile et chaque année
on tremble le principal financement pour
nous à 50 ans en Yvelines c'est la
communauté d'agglomération
puis la caisse d'allocation familiale
l'État avec diverlines budgétaires et ce
qu'on appelle l'action logement
autrefois le 1% patronal donc on est
financé par toute une série de de
structures qui sont intéressées au
logement des jeunes et aujourd'hui
l'équilibre est très juste on attend des
réponses
on n'a pas le sentiment que notre
mission soit remise en question
néanmoins donc ça c'est important
on reconnaît
le travail qui est fait on reconnaît la
qualité du travail et les flux que l'on
traite bon c'est vrai que c'est de
l'accueil et de la formation et de
l'orientation c'est de l'aide au
démarche acclage à pas vocation à
construire ou à résoudre les problèmes
que doit traiter une collectivité locale
en termes de création de logement c'est
tout à fait différent là nous on est
centré sur l'accompagnement des jeunes
et je pense que notre mission n'est pas
questionnée en tant que tel ce qui est
questionné c'est les ressources globales
de notre vie et de nos choix politiques
et vos services sont gratuits pour les
jeunes qui veulent bien évidemment
rentrer en contact avec vous juste pour
conclure on va repréciser le site
Internet a été refait s'il y a une
nouvelle méthode pour rentrer en contact
sur Internet aussi
un jeune 50 ans en Yvelines il tombe
tout de suite sur notre site alors une
réponse
mail sur internet des fois ça répond pas
toujours non il y a des réponses qui
sont apportées rapidement c'est
important j'imagine pour ceux qui nous
regardent oui nous sommes surpris du
fait que
ce site qui vient d'être fait qui est
très nouveau fonctionne déjà très bien
il y a au moins plus d'une demande qui
nous arrive par jour on sait qu'il y a
une vingtaine de demandes mais certains
s'inscrivent pour venir nous voir au
clash à partir de ce site et ça on s'y
attendait pas le fait qu'il y a autant
de demandes n'est pas forcément un bon
indicateur de sur le terrain de la
réalité des difficultés j'imagine avoir
moins de demandes ce que veut dire quoi
c'est qu'on n'a pas fait du tout de
marketing sur l'ouverture de la nouvelle
version du site mais que la nouveauté
c'est que le jeûne peut s'inscrire et
donc là maintenant il ne restera pas
dans la nature avec juste des
informations telles que c'était avant il
aura l'accompagnement merci à tous les
deux d'être venu au plateau donc pour
parler des 20 ans du clash on reste à
Trappes où sont installés s d'ailleurs
vos locaux mais nous allons cette
fois-ci sur les terrains du club de
football l'Étoile Sportive de Trappes
qui compte à présent 1000 licenciés une
barre symbolique qui a été franchie
Anthony Reich
avec tous ces licenciés trappes
pourraient composer 90 équipes mais
au-delà de l'aspect purement quantitatif
ce chiffre de 1000 licenciés est un
symbole de qualité de la formation
trapiste en l'espace de 10 ans le club a
formé de nombreux éducateurs diplômés
pour rencontrer désormais une
cinquantaine nous le nombre ça n'est pas
du tout
important si on a augmenté comme ça je
pense que c'est vraiment le travail qui
a eu depuis des années qui a été mis en
place et surtout la qualité la qualité
qui peut être vraiment de partout chez
les joueurs chez les dirigeants chez les
parents depuis 2004 l'Étoile Sportive de
trappe a gagné 50% d'adhérents désormais
la formation du club est reconnue
au-delà des frontières de la ville que
cela soit sur les pelouses de Guimier ou
sans sac ici le football est réservé à
tous à l'image de la nouvelle équipe
féminine qui a pris forme en début de
saison j'étais joueur
j'estime que à l'école de foot c'est le
passage le plus important pour un enfant
c'est là où est-ce qu'on apprend les
bases donc c'est dès les bases
on les a pas c'est difficile ensuite de
monter sur les catégories différentes
avec trois équipes de jeunes évoluant en
Ligue régionale depuis 2006 l'Étoile
Sportive de Trappes a permis à huit
jeunes footballeurs d'intégrer des
centres de formation à l'image de Nissim
rafaf parti pour Laval quand l'enfant
est bon il est bon c'est à dire que si
ce garçon c'est un Anelka si ce garçon
est un Zidane si ce garçon est un messie
alors c'est un joueur d'exception on
fera en sorte qu'ils deviennent celui
qui doit être pour le coup si c'est un
gamin qui a beaucoup moins de
possibilités qui a allez on va dire un
niveau moindre on le fera aller au bout
de ce qui est capable de produire sur
cette saison 2014-2015 Trap est
désormais le premier club des Yvelines
devant Houilles ou encore Versailles en
termes de licencié
excellente soirée sur tvfils 78 ce sera
notamment avec Floran parfait pour un
nouveau numéro de Philippo magazine
économique hebdomadaire de la rédaction
je vous retrouverai demain vendredi pour
le dernier journal de la semaine
excellente soirée donc